I mean how long have we been waiting now
for a good burger sequel you know we've
been talking about it for a second and
finally you dropped the news ladies and
gentlemen
Kel has something he'd like to tell you
wow all right here we go Kel whenever
you're ready ladies and gentlemen oh wow
welcome to Good Burger homie the Good
Burger part two
[Music]
[Applause]
vote for on Jimmy Fallon and said the
fans are finally going to get the sequel
so how did Good Burger 2 come about uh
where where we find an indexer these
days man well Ed is running the place so
you can imagine how that might go
hot mess Express
yeah and then Dexter's still up to us
he's you know crazy Antics and uh good
burger you know like into a little bit
of trouble but that's all we can tell
you
great uh
I should have figured that lunch with
you would be different
give out too much oh come on you can
tell me more
I might not even be that deep no okay
are you all in production on it already
no we will be soon though yeah yeah well
if you need ET to make a little set
visit we definitely do give me a holler
we definitely do because we want to get
the word out as much as possible it's
very exciting like we just announced it
last night you know so like that was you
know an intense kind of 12 24 hour kind
of turn around to see like everybody's
like excited like they always respond
pretty positively when we like you know
hint at maybe it's possibly going to
happen or whatever but to give it the
official goal was just a very special
feeling and yeah yeah everybody's really
excited but now it's like let's get the
product out there yeah let's get it out
give the people what they want exactly
did okay okay soundtracks yeah forget
about the Good Burger home of the Good
Burger can I take your order welcome to
get Burger home of the Good Burger
what are you my sister is that your
sister bro I think that's my sister I
know I could be well Kelly's already
taken yeah
y'all
I love that I can't yeah I can't it's
y'all y'all we can play on that little
people I'm sure
why does this work why did Keaton and
Kel work so well together man I mean
it's you know like it's a Brotherhood
but it's also like an appreciation of
Senses of humor I think you know what I
mean we're also like very similar young
black children like both of our moms are
five foot and Don't Take No Mess you
know
Atlanta Chicago like you know similar
City similar experiences blah blah so we
just had a lot you know to connect with
like in the beginning to relate to each
other whatever but he makes me laugh so
much I hopefully make him laugh you know
what I mean you do all the time back and
forth like that and it makes work not
feel like work yeah it's just fun all
the time
[Music]
thank you